hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip my name is cameron and today
we're talking about camera
lens blur using gradients and this is a
really powerful technique to have a lot
of control
over your blur your gradient that's
that's
affecting your blur map so let me show
what i'm talking about
i have an image here it's a pre-comp
image
it's just a composition i find that this
works best if the pre-comp is set to the
same size of our composition so our
composition is 1920 by 1080
and that's what size this pre-comp is
here it is it's a
1920 by 1080 pre-comp you can see the
image is quite
large which is why i brought it into a
pre-comp here
i've also applied a camera lens blur
here and i've just
reset it to 5 as a blur radius
now what i want to show you here is if
you create a new shape layer so
make sure nothing's selected and just
double-click
your rectangle tool here and it's going
to create a new shape layer
okay and it's defaulting my computer
last used
a radial gradient and i want to just
select a linear gradient just like this
and working with these gradients you can
see
we have these these handles here okay
now i can tell i can turn this layer off
i can tell my image
camera lens blur i can tell the blur map
layer
to look at that shape layer and change
this blur map based upon that so if i
crank up the blur
instead of applying it to the entire
image here i'm going to go ahead and
repeat edge pixels here
instead of applying the entire blur map
to this entire layer
i can select my shape layer my gradient
and it's going to look at the white and
black values and that how is how it
determines
the gradient what's cool about this
effect is that i can turn this layer on
i can make it an adjustment layer and
now i can't see the layer
but i can select my rectangle fill
and i can adjust the gradient
this way right so i can get a lot of
control here
for how i want my image to look while
seeing the image it's a very
powerful easy way to adjust the lens
blur
effect this way so you can see here
you know i can get a lot of control i
can also go into my
gradient editor here and really you know
play with these values
the gray values and really get some
really interesting
looks so that's using the linear
gradient i'm going to show you the
radial gradient as well so i'll go into
my pre-comp here
i'll turn on my image above which is an
i thought this would be kind of cool to
show with the
radial gradient change my fill to
instead of linear to radial click ok
and again i can come in here and select
like if i want the center point of my
eye to be in focus
like that you know just get some really
interesting looks this way
and uh obviously i could go in and play
around with my blur radius
you know make it much more intense a
little bit less intense
uh go into things like the highlight
mode
and play around with those kind of
settings as well but that is how you can
use a shape layer
gradient fill to control your camera
lens blur
with a lot of control over
how the blur map is working